Professor Charles
Bailyn: Welcome to prefrosh
[newly admitted students
visiting during Yale's "Bulldog
Days" program].
I'm talking about black holes
at 8 o'clock this evening.
Come listen to that,
too, and in the meantime,
we'll talk about the future of
the Universe.
Okay.
Logistical questions?
Anything?
All right.
Where were we?
We were here.
This is the data that
demonstrate that the Universe is
filled with dark energy,
a kind of anti-gravity that is
pushing the Universe apart.
And what this is--this is the
same data on both of these
plots, just plotted slightly
differently.
On the top plot,
what they've done is they've
plotted the apparent magnitude
of these supernovae versus their
redshift.
And so, apparent
magnitude--because the absolute
magnitude is always the same.
These are standard candles.
So, from the apparent
magnitude, you can figure out
what the distance modulus is.
That gives you a measure of the
distance.
So, this is just distance
versus velocity.
Now, we've plotted distance
versus velocity of bunch of
times.
That's the Hubble Diagram.
Most of the times we've plotted
it, it's come out on a straight
line.
Do you understand why this plot
isn't on a straight line?
The top one,
I'm talking about,
now--why those lines are
curved?
What's the y-axis?
The y-axis is--yes?
Student: It's
logarithmic.
Professor Charles
Bailyn: It's logarithmic.
Thank you very much.
Yes, it's magnitude.
Magnitudes are upside down and
logarithmic, right?
That's why faint stars have
high numbers up at the top.
And because one axis is
logarithmic and the other axis
isn't, of course,
it curves.
You could--the way--if you want
a nice straight line,
you just make this axis
logarithmic, as well.
What we've done down on the
bottom is just subtracted off
the empty Universe--a Universe
with no matter and no energy in
it--so that you can see more
clearly the way these three
lines diverge.
And these three lines are three
different models of the
Universe.
And they're denoted by these Ω
factors.
Ω _matter,
that's the density of matter
divided by the critical density.
Ω_λ,
that's the energy density of
the dark energy divided by that
same critical density.
And down here is an Ω
_matter of 1.
That's the dividing line
between a Universe that
re-collapses and a Universe that
expands forever.
So, if the Universe were--if
the points that we studied were
down here, the Universe would
re-collapse.
If they're up here, it wouldn't.
This dotted line here is 1/4
and 0.
1/4 in Ω_matter is
the amount of matter that we
actually observe in dark matter
and galaxies.
If you go out and count up all
the dark matter in the galaxies,
add it all up,
you get to about 1/4 of the
critical density.
So, what people were kind of
expecting to see was something
between here and here.
And, of course,
that wasn't what happened,
as we discussed last time.
Turns out, all the points are
too high, and therefore,
you end with a current best
fit--the best guess for the way
of the Universe is this solid
line here.
This is called the standard
model or the concordance model,
where you've got a 1/4 of--the
Ω_matter is 1/4,
but there's a whole bunch of
dark energy.
3/4 of the Universe is in this
mysterious form of dark energy,
which tends to push things
apart rather than pull them
together.
That's why these points are
above the 0 line,
instead of below it.
And that's the current best
idea for what the Universe is.
So, by virtue of the fact that
these points lie on the solid
line rather than on somewhere
between these two dotted lines,
or perhaps even below,
we make this remarkable
conclusion: that the Universe is
3/4 full of something we
absolutely don't understand,
called dark energy,
which has the effect of an
anti-gravity.
And then, it turns out that
Einstein's biggest mistake is
right after all.
Pretty hefty conclusion to lay
on the basis of two dozen points
with, let it be said,
pretty sizeable error bars on
any one of those points.
And so, I thought,
at the start of today,
I would talk about what these
points are,
how they are measured,
and what could go wrong with
this kind of measurement.
Because, you know,
we've transformed what we think
about the Universe based on
this.
And so, it behooves one to
actually try and understand
what's going on.
I'll come back to that in a
minute.
So, what are these points?
What are we measuring?
And why do we think it might
even work?
What we are measuring is Type
Ia Supernovae.
So, this is typically
astronomical nomenclature,
right?
We go out.
We find a bunch of things.
We divide them into categories.
We call them Type I, Type 2.
It then turns out that each of
those categories has
sub-categories,
Type Ia.
The joke is when astronomers
find three objects,
that's two categories and an
exception.
Type Ia Supernovae,
though, are by now a fairly
well-defined category,
and here's what we think they
are.
Think back to the middle part
of the class--to the black hole
section of the class,
where we were talking about
x-ray binaries.
X-ray binary,
you'll recall,
is a black hole in orbit around
something--some other kind of
star,
and it pulls material from that
other star onto itself.
So, Type I Supernovae come from
a very similar category of
objects.
Here's a normal star,
except it's pulled out of shape
a little bit,
and it's in a double star
system.
Here's something else.
This is a white dwarf.
In this case,
you will remember,
white dwarfs are these very
compact stars--not compact
enough to be black holes,
but fairly compact--that are
created at the end of the
lifetime of stars like the Sun.
So, a fairly dense object.
And just as in the x-ray
binaries, stuff is being pulled
off of the normal star onto the
white dwarf.
So, then, what happens to this
stuff?
First of all,
the white dwarf has had all its
hydrogen and helium fused
together, so there's no hydrogen
or helium left.
So, this white dwarf is
composed of elements like carbon
and oxygen and nitrogen and
neon, and so on,
up the line,
but no hydrogen and helium.
So, the material that comes
from the normal stars,
full of hydrogen and
helium--it's pretty much all
hydrogen and helium.
So, the accreted material,
what does it do?
Lands on the white dwarf.
And as it lands, it heats up.
It falls down.
It heats up,
gets very hot,
gets very dense.
And so, it undergoes nuclear
fusion, just like the material
in the middle of the Sun or in
the middle, presumably,
of this normal star,
as well.
So, there's all this fusion
going on.
One of the features of the way
this works on a white dwarf is
it is usually true that what
happens is hydrogen and helium
piles up for a while,
and then, it has a big
explosion.
It doesn't usually burn
steadily.
And so, what actually happens
is, you have occasional
thermonuclear explosions of the
accreted material.
And so, you pile up all this
hydrogen and you wait some
amount of time,
somewhere between 10 days and
10^(5) years,
depending on the object.
You pile up all this hydrogen
and helium and finally it gets
dense and hot enough to explode,
and then it explodes all at
once.
Huge hydrogen bomb on the
surface of this white dwarf.
And that makes the system much,
much brighter,
because there's all this stuff
exploding.
This is the phenomenon we call
a nova, because it looked to the
ancients as if a new star had
appeared, because the thing had
gotten so much brighter.
Okay.
So, stuff piles up.
Novae occur.
More stuff piles up.
More novae occur.
And one of the things that's
happening while this is going on
is that the white dwarf is
gradually getting more massive,
because it's piling up all this
extra material.
Oh, the consequence of the nova
is that all the hydrogen and
helium gets fused into carbon,
oxygen, nitrogen,
neon, and so forth.
So then, it looks just like the
rest of the white dwarf,
gets assimilated into the white
dwarf, except the white dwarf is
bigger now.
So, the white dwarf gets more
massive and gradually more,
and more, and more massive.
But, you may recall,
there's a limit to how this
long could go on.
The reason there's a limit to
how long this can go on is
because of something we talked
about before that Chandrasekhar
Limit,
which says that white dwarfs
cannot be more massive than 1.4
times the mass of the Sun.
So, what happens when this
white dwarf, which starts out at
some perfectly respectable mass,
0.
6 of the Sun,
or 1 solar mass.
And it's piling up all this
material from its friend,
and gradually getting more and
more massive,
and then, it reaches this
limit, this Chandrasekhar limit.
So then, what happens?
What happens--remember what the
Chandrasekhar limit is.
If you've got a white dwarf
that's bigger than the
Chandrasekhar limit,
then the white dwarf cannot
hold itself up against gravity,
and so, the whole thing
collapses all at once.
And, as is generally the case,
when it collapses,
it gets hot.
It gets dense.
That's what generally happens
in a collapse.
And so, the carbon,
in particular,
but all the other elements as
well--so, carbon and other
elements in the white dwarf
fuse,
and that generates energy.
And they fuse together to form
heavy elements such as iron,
and heavier than that,
all at once.
So what happens is,
every time this occurs,
you have exactly the same
amount of stuff.
This always happens when you
have 1.4 solar mass white
dwarfs, because that's the
limit.
You've gradually built up to
that limit.
And so, you have what you might
refer to as a standard bomb.
We've talked about standard
candles.
This is a standard bomb.
You always have the same amount
of material and it all explodes
at once.
Well, actually,
it takes about,
what?
A hundred milliseconds,
something like that,
but basically,
all at once.
So, you blow up 1.4 solar
masses of carbon all at once.
Now, the advantage of standard
things is that if you have a
standard bomb with the same
amount of fuel,
every one of them should be
exactly as bright as every other
one, and that's what we need to
make these distance
measurements.
Remember?
So, if you look at these
things, you see that they're
always the same brightness,
so, they're terrific standard
candles.
And so, one of the things that
happens is that you look at
these things and you can tell,
from how bright they look,
exactly how far away they are.
You also measure their redshift
when they blow up in this way,
and you get to put a point on
that redshift versus distance
plot.
And they're stupendously bright.
These things have an absolute
magnitude of -19.5.
They outshine whole galaxies,
for about a week or two,
until they go away.
And so, you can see them at
enormous distances.
So, they're just about the
perfect thing for exploring
cosmology.
But we were only really able to
do this in the--starting in the
early 1990s, because there were
two key advances that were made
at that time.
One is that the Hubble Space
Telescope measured things like
Cepheids and other kinds of
stars,
other kinds of distance
measurements,
in galaxies that historically
had Type Ia Supernovae.
These things don't occur very
often, once every couple of 100
years per galaxy.
There hasn't been one in our
own galaxy since before they
invented the telescope.
We're kind of overdue, actually.
One of the worrying things–
You know, it would be great to
have one of these supernovae in
our galaxy.
We could study it enormously
carefully.
The problem is,
all the telescopes are too big
and--because it would burn out
all the instruments.
You put one of these big
research telescopes pointing to
it.
So, one of the things that we
have, just in case,
sort of, for emergencies in the
telescopes I've worked with in
Chile,
is we have a big thing you can
put over the front of the
telescope and stop it down to
about a couple of inches across,
just in case there's a Type
Ia super--any kind of
supernovae in our own galaxy.
But when these--we do have
supernovae in the historical
record.
Kepler and Tycho saw one.
And then, back in the eleventh
century, there was a famous one
observed by the Chinese and Arab
astronomers.
The Europeans were,
of course, in barbarity at the
time and didn't even notice.
And--which, now,
we see the Crab Nebula,
which is a big outward-going
explosion.
And these things become the
brightest objects in the sky.
You can see them in the daytime.
Pretty amazing,
but it hasn't happened for 400
years, at least,
in our own galaxy.
Student: How long did
you say they lasted?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: They last--well,
I'll show you in a minute what
the light curve looks like.
They take a couple weeks to
rise to their maximum
brightness, and then they decay
over a few months.
So, you can see them for a
little while.
So, it just--measured Cepheids.
This meant that we could
calibrate them.
Remember the distance ladder?
So, you could calibrate these
things – calibration.
And this, in particular,
meant that we know the absolute
magnitude, which is crucial for
determining these distances.
What, then, came out of that
and other things,
mostly, actually,
done with ground-based
telescopes--so,
ground-based telescopes
discovered and compared many of
these things,
many of these Type Ias,
and discovered that,
you know, it isn't actually
quite true that they all look to
be the same brightness.
Because, it would be true,
if you could measure all of the
energy that came out of these
things.
But that isn't actually what
you measure.
What you measure is all of the
photons in a certain
range--depending on your
detector and how you set your
telescope up--all photons within
a certain range of wavelengths
at a certain time.
And that is not the same thing
as measuring all the energy that
the thing gives out.
And so, it turns out that if
you measure all photons in some
wavelength region at some time,
that actually varies from one
object to another.
This can vary by,
oh, I don't know,
15 - 20%, but that's enough to
cause you some real trouble in
making these measurements.
But what they discovered was
that you can correct for this.
If you measure the color and
the decay rate--that is to say,
how fast it gets fainter.
So, your question turns out to
be very important.
These things behave differently
depending on how fast they go
away.
If you measure the color and
the decay rate,
you can correct for some of
these deviations and turn it
back it into a good standard
candle.
And I'll show you how this is
done in just a second,
okay?
How we doing?
Okay, let me turn this off for
a second and go back to here.
All right.
This is the key thing that was
found out in the early 1990s.
Up on the top,
you have observations from a
whole bunch of supernovae.
This is time.
So, this is 0,20 days,
40 days, 60 days.
So, this is time,
counting from the peak
brightness.
And most of the time you can
observe these things before they
get to peak brightness.
You watch them get brighter and
then you watch them get fainter.
In the top plot there,
we're plotting,
more or less,
absolute magnitude.
Think of it--it's a complicated
thing, but think of it as
absolute magnitude.
So -19.5, as I said,
is a typical
magnitude--absolute magnitude.
And each color is a different
supernova.
So, they've made repeated
observations of a large number
of supernovae.
And then, the line is just
connecting the dots,
connecting the observations.
And you can see from that top
plot that it is not true,
that every supernova has the
same brightness,
at peak or at any other time.
And so, the green supernova on
the bottom there gets up to
about -18.8, whereas,
the orange one on the top gets
up to about -20.
That's almost a factor of 3 in
difference of peak brightness.
But then you can make this
correction.
They measure the color of the
thing, which is not apparent on
this particular plot.
They measure the rate of decay,
and that is apparent.
You can tell the green ones,
the ones at the bottom,
tend to fall off faster than
the ones at the top.
And they came up with a
correction formula that allows
the absolute magnitudes of these
things to be corrected,
and that's what they plot here.
These are these same exact data
points as they have on the top
line, except corrected for the
differences in observed color
and observed decay rate.
And you can see,
now, you've got a very
beautiful combined light curve
where everything does exactly
the same thing as all the
others.
And, in particular,
the maximum brightness of these
things is always the same at
around -19.5.
So, you have to make this
correction in order to be able
to use these things effectively
as standard candles.
And so, when that was done,
and we had calibrated this,
and they thought,
well,
now we know,
every time we see one of these
things, we'll just follow it up,
follow it down,
make this correction,
and then we have--we know what
the absolute magnitude is.
We measure the apparent
magnitude.
We determine the distance.
We get a spectrum along the way
so that we can get a redshift.
And then, we can make these
plots for distant objects.
These guys aren't particularly
distant, because you want to be
able to get really accurate
measurements of them.
And so, if this set were the
ones that were observed so close
to us at such low redshifts that
you can't tell the different
cosmological models apart.
So then, people got very fired
up.
They said, aha,
we're going to figure out
everything that is happening in
the Universe by looking at these
supernovae.
And they started up big
observational projects to find
many high redshift supernovae.
So, these things are going to
be quite faint.
They're going to be--they have
distance moduluses of close to
45, and so, they'll have an
apparent magnitude as low as 25,
which is really very hard to
see.
So here's what they do.
First of all,
let me just show you this
picture.
This is just fun.
Let's see, here.
If I do this,
that will be good,
except I think I want this.
There we go--all right.
This is a photograph from the
Hubble Space Telescope of empty
space.
They picked a part of the sky
in which there was nothing.
Actually, that's not true.
There was one star,
one faint star that they knew
about, and nothing else.
And they took the space
telescope and they looked at it
for about three weeks in a row.
And this is the picture they
got.
You can see two or three stars
in this picture.
This is one,
and there are a couple of
others scattered around.
You can tell they're stars
because they have this,
sort of, spike pattern from the
optics of the telescope.
Everything else that you see in
this picture is a galaxy.
There's a whole galaxy,
each one of them with billions
of stars.
There are, I think,
13,000 of them?
8,000?
How many in the ultra deep
field?
I don't remember.
Huh?
Student: Are any of them
lensed?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: A couple of them are
lensed, but most of them,
not.
So, most of them are just
straight-up images of galaxies.
You could see,
in the bigger ones,
some nice spirals and all the
usual kinds of galaxy shapes.
This is a really small piece of
the sky.
This is a piece of the sky
about 1% of the area of the full
Moon.
So, if you looked at the whole
area covered by the full
Moon--picture the full Moon up
in the sky--and you did this
kind of picture,
you would discover literally
millions of different galaxies.
So, this means that you can
discover supernovae in the--so,
there are thousands of
galaxies, here.
And if supernovae occur once
per every 100 years per galaxy,
there ought to be about ten or
twenty supernovae going off in
this tiny piece of space right
now.
Or any other such tiny piece of
space.
And so, if you're looking for
high redshift supernovae,
you don't care where you point.
They're everywhere.
And so, you just pick out some
nice blank piece of space,
take really deep pictures of
them, and wait for the
supernovae to start showing up.
And this is what people have
done.
So, here's a little bit of data
from the Supernova Cosmology
Project, which is one of the
groups that was attempting to do
this in the 1990s.
So, in the background,
here, is just a huge field of
stars that they happened to be
looking at.
Then, they've taken this tiny
piece of the sky and blown it
up.
So, here's their first image of
it.
By the way, this,
and this, and this--these are
galaxies, but they're taken from
the ground instead of with the
space telescope.
And so, they look like blobby
things.
You can't see any of the
structure.
And then, three weeks later
they take another picture,
and it turns out,
there's a little extra light on
the side of one of the galaxies.
Now, imagine taking something
maybe 100 times bigger than this
whole background picture and
looking for that difference.
You would make your graduate
students completely cross-eyed
doing this.
And so, they do it digitally.
They do it differently.
What you do is you take this
picture, each one of these
pixels, you know,
tells you exactly how many
photons hit it.
So, it's all digitized.
Each one of these is a number.
And you just take this number
and subtract this number.
And you take the number from
each pixel, subtract the number
that you got in the previous
thing and get a subtracted image
of how much light there is,
minus the light there was the
last time you looked at it.
Here's the subtracted picture.
Now this, even a blind old
professor can see,
has something interesting going
on.
There's a new object that has
appeared between the first
picture and the second picture.
Now, up at the top,
in the upper right-hand corner
there, that's a Hubble Space
Telescope picture taken of the
same field,
while the supernova was in
outburst.
And you can see,
this galaxy,
here.
That's the galaxy,
you know, below the arrow
there.
And then, those two arrows are
placed in exactly the same
relative position in these two
pictures.
And so, in the Hubble Space
Telescope picture,
you can see that the additional
light comes from a particular
point in the outskirts of the
galaxy.
But it wasn't discovered with
the Hubble Space Telescope,
because the HST doesn't cover
enough of the sky at once.
So, you try and discover these
things from the ground,
because you can cover so much
more of the sky.
And so, this is a discovery
image.
And then, if you want more
precise imaging,
then you have to tell Hubble,
or go and look at this
particular place.
Anyway, what they do is they
keep at it.
They keep at it.
Every three days,
they make one of these
pictures.
They make these difference
pictures, and they get these
nice light curves.
And out of those light curves,
they can then do the correction
factor.
And then, once you've done
that--you also take a spectrum
along the way for two purposes:
first of all,
to get the redshift;
second of all,
to make sure that it's a Type
Ia Supernova,
rather than any of the other
five or six subtypes.
And then, you put them on this
plot and you plot their apparent
magnitude, corrected by these
various factors,
against the redshift.
And that's how you come up with
these kinds of data.
So, that's where this
information comes from.
And there is,
as you see, a kind of
theoretical--both a theoretical
reason and an observational
reason to trust these results.
So, there is a theoretical
basis for thinking these things
are standard candles--namely,
that it's the same amount of
fuel each time one of these
things goes off.
And there's also an empirical
basis, which is that after some
corrections, the nearby ones
line up beautifully.
The nearby ones,
for which you know the answer
in advance by other means--the
nearby ones line up well.
And where by "well",
I mean less than 5% difference
between them.
And there still is about a few
percent difference.
But if we observe enough of
them, we can average over that
and we think we're going to be
okay.
So, if you want to come up with
some kind of explanation for
this that does not involve dark
energy, you've got to get around
both of these points;
namely, the fact that we expect
them to look like each other,
and the fact that they do look
like each other.
Now, it's possible to do that
and, in fact,
one of the problems on the
problem set addresses just this
issue.
If you can invent some way that
all of the supernovae at a
redshift of .8,
high redshifts like that,
are all systematically fainter
than otherwise identical-looking
supernovae in the nearby
Universe,
then you can get around this
problem.
But they have to be
identical-looking in the sense
that they have the same color
and decay rate,
but are fainter.
We don't see that in the local
Universe.
We don't see a category of
things, which have the same
color and decay rate,
but one is fainter than the
other.
But, who knows?
The Universe was,
you know, half its size back
then.
All sorts of things were
different.
Maybe there's some way that
supernovae then were
systematically different from
how they are now,
except that they don't show it
in these particular ways.
They only show it in the
overall brightness.
That's tough.
That's tough, theoretically.
It's tough empirically.
You know, you would expect that
if that were true,
then there would be
intermediate cases that we could
see, and we don't see them.
But, you know,
shortly after this result was
announced, I used to--when I was
at conferences and stuff,
I would try and take the
supernovae people off in a
corner and give them beer and
stuff,
until they would,
you know--and then,
after you give them four beers,
you ask the question,
what could be going wrong?
Do you really believe in dark
energy?
And then, they start mumbling
stuff about all the different
weirdnesses that supernovae
have.
And, of course,
these are people who have
devoted their life to studying
the weirdness of supernovae,
and so, they have many things
that they will tell you under
cover of darkness.
Which, of course,
then, everybody went out to try
and check.
And none of these things have
turned out to be able to provide
a satisfactory explanation for
the data,
except the idea that there's
something very significant,
cosmologically,
going on.
Okay, so, from that point of
view, it's kind of hard to avoid
believing this,
which disturbed a lot of
people.
And, in fact,
one of the reasons people
believed this as quickly as they
did was that in the late--in
1998,
when this was first announced,
it was not announced by one
group, it was announced by two
different groups.
There were two groups trying to
do the same thing--doing the
same thing and theyso,
they were sort of spying on
each other, because this was an
important result.
And they both found out,
at a certain point,
that the other guys had been
spending a year driving
themselves crazy because they
didn't believe their results.
They were saying,
look at this,
these things are getting--these
things are going totally in the
wrong direction.
We must be wrong somehow.
And it turned out that both of
these groups had been spending
the past year trying to figure
out why their results were so
screwed up.
But then, they spied on each
other and they found out that
the other guys were having the
exact same problem,
having taken their data and
dealt with it in quite a
different way.
And so, then,
miraculously enough,
they kind of submitted their
papers within twenty-four hours
of each other,
so they both got credit.
And so, the two groups doing
the same things,
but doing them differently.
Different approaches,
in some ways,
got the same result.
And in particular,
one group were a bunch of
particle physicists led by Saul
Perlmutter,
who had gotten depressed by the
fact that the Super Collider was
cancelled in the early 1990s,
and had decided--somebody
described this as "adult onset
cosmology," where you used to be
interested in particle physics,
but then, they didn't build
your machine,
so now you're interested in
astrophysics.
And those guys took a very
particle physics approach to it.
They had a big team,
with a team leader and a whole
hierarchy.
The other guys were a bunch of
supernova--and they were very
expert in the cosmology side of
things,
and in the dark energy
explanations,
and stuff like that.
The supernova experts,
the sort of guys who knew all
the weirdnesses about
supernovae, formed another
group, but it was totally
differently organized.
It was kind of a loose
confederation of small research
groups here and there.
They had done this interesting
work with the correction factors
on supernovae some years before,
and they approached it as,
you know, my group will do this
little piece.
My group will do this other
We'll get together over lunch
and we'll figure out what's
going on, kind of thing.
And they both got the same
kinds of answers.
They both basically got the
same answers.
And so, this is one of the
fables.
So, fable: discovery of dark
energy.
And I would say that the moral
here is that replicating
important results is one of the
things that leads people to
actually believe what you're
saying--leads to greater
acceptance.
And it was particularly nice in
this particular case,
because neither of them were
replicating the others.
They both made the discovery
independently,
at the same time,
using a very different kind of
organizational structure and a
very different approach to their
data.
So, this was kind of compelling.
Okay.
So, here we are,
Δ (m – M),
versus redshift.
Here's Ω _matter = 0.
Ω_λ = 0,
except that,
in fact, the data--you know,
they kind of look like this.
So, this is Ω
_matter = 1/4 and
Ω_λ = 3/4.
And, as you will recall,
the explanation for this--or,
the first explanation that was
offered was the fact that
Einstein had this figured out
eighty years before,
except he decided he was wrong.
And so, the first explanation
of this was Einstein's
Cosmological Constant--that's
this symbol, lambda [λ],
that I keep writing down.
And so, once people believed
this result, you had to start
worrying about what the heck
this actually is in real life.
And it has some very peculiar
properties.
In particular,
there is the issue of what is
constant about Einstein's
Cosmological Constant?
So, let me first tell you what
it is, and then,
I'll tell you why it's so
bizarre.
The energy density –
remember, that's the crucial
quantity--of λ is constant as
the Universe expands.
So, if you take 1 cubic meter
of space, and you say,
how much dark energy is there
in this cubic meter of space?
We take an average cubic meter
of space.
You figure that out by how fast
the Universe is being pushed
apart.
And then, you know,
you wait 10 billion years,
or something like that,
until the Universe is very much
bigger.
And then, you take a cubic
meter of space,
and you ask yourself how much
dark energy is in this cubic
meter,
and you get the same answer,
10 billion years later.
And you got the same answer
now, and you would have gotten
the same answer 10 billion years
ago.
Very peculiar, right?
Do you see why?
Think about matter.
You know, the Universe also has
a bunch of matter in it.
All right, so I measure the
average density of the Universe
in the way we've discussed,
and you get some answer.
So, for matter,
you can get some density to the
Universe now.
And then, supposing you imagine
in your mind,
you go back in time when--to
the time when the scale factor
of the Universe,
when a was half its
present size,
its present amount.
But, of course,
you have the same amount of
matter in the Universe.
Matter doesn't--you know,
in general, it doesn't get
created.
Or, at least,
you have the same amount of
matter plus energy.
So, you go back to when you
have the same amount of matter,
but it's in half the size,
by which I mean,
1/8 the volume,
right?
Half squared--half cubed is 1/8.
And so, if I reduce the linear
scale of the Universe by a
factor of two,
I have 1/8 the volume,
but same amount of matter.
So rho_then,
which is equal to mass,
which doesn't change,
because there's the same amount
of mass in the Universe,
which doesn't change,
divided by volume,
which does change.
So, it has to equal eight times
the density_now.
We've talked about this before,
right?
The whole deal with the Big
Bang is that if you go back into
the past, things were denser
than they were today.
Also hotter,
which is a by-product of the
density.
You take a big balloon full of
stuff.
You make it smaller.
The same amount of stuff is in
there.
It's got to be denser inside
the balloon after you've
squashed it down.
You take a balloon and you
stretch it out.
If you don't let stuff come in
or out, then it has to be less
dense--the stuff inside,
after you've stretched it out.
And then, you get into all
these nice little thermodynamics
problems where you have,
pressure is equal to density
times temperature,
and things like that.
So, all of familiar gas physics
comes into play.
And so, you expect that the
density of the Universe is
constantly getting smaller,
because the Universe is getting
bigger.
And, in fact,
there's extremely good
empirical evidence of that,
because you look back in time
by looking at distant things.
Sure enough,
it's denser back then.
But not the dark energy.
Dark energy density,
at least in Einstein's
conception, is constant.
So, a cubic meter of the
Universe has the same amount of
dark energy in it now as a cubic
meter of the Universe did when
the Universe was only a cubic
meter across,
right?
Where the whole observable
Universe was packed down into a
cubic meter, that cubic meter
had only as much dark energy in
it as,
you know, this part of the
Universe does now.
Very odd behavior,
but this is what Einstein's
equations predict.
Now, the thing is,
we don't know that Einstein
really was right.
We don't, because we don't have
a clue what the dark energy
actually is.
So let me--so,
λ, the Cosmological Constant,
suggests that dark energy has
constant density.
But, since we don't know what
the heck this stuff is,
maybe that's wrong.
Or maybe not.
If it's not,
we don't call it λ anymore.
But if you allow for changes in
the density, you can get very
interesting potential effects.
And let me--we'll talk about
this more next time,
but let me just describe one of
the very strange things that
could happen.
Suppose it is true--and this is
not ruled out by the data we
have so far.
Suppose the dark energy density
increases as the Universe gets
bigger.
And since we don't have any
idea what this stuff is,
it might do that,
and we can't rule it out by
observations just yet.
And so, the Universe gets
bigger and bigger.
The density of the matter is
going down, because you have the
same amount of matter in a
bigger space.
But, supposing we invent some
kind of dark energy where the
density actually gets bigger as
the Universe increases in size.
Then, a cubic meter of volume
has increasing dark energy as
time goes along.
That, of course,
pushes the Universe out faster,
so the acceleration increases.
That makes the size increase
and you get a feedback as the
Universe exponentially expands.
You get an exponential
expansion.
And as that exponential
expansion increases,
the amount of dark energy in
any particular cubic meter gets
bigger too.
And so, what happens?
After a while,
the dark energy in any cubic
galaxy has become so much that
it blows the galaxy apart.
Gravity can't hold the galaxy
together.
And then, the expansion
continues.
And then, after a while,
the amount of dark energy in
one cubic star,
if I can use that term,
in one star becomes so great
that it overcomes the gravity of
the star and it blows the star
apart.
And then, the expansion
continues even faster.
And after a while,
the amount of dark energy in a
cubic meter--that would be a
human being.
Remember, human beings are
exactly a cubic meter and
exactly 100 kilograms in mass.
The amount of dark energy in a
human being overcomes the
chemical bonds that hold your
body together and human beings
get blown apart.
And eventually,
you have so much dark matter
that whole atoms--that atoms get
blown to bits,
and even the sub-atomic
particles that are within them
eventually get blown to bits.
And so, dark energy conquers
all.
This is described as the Big
Rip, and it is kind of an
alternative hypothesis of what
might happen to the Universe,
that stems from an alternative
hypothesis of what the dark
energy is, that there's no
particular reason to believe,
but that hasn't been disproved.
And since there's no particular
reason to believe anything else,
you can amuse your students by
talking about it.
So, to summarize this,
here is--it's all a question of
the scale factor versus time.
Here is now.
Here is 1.
Here is an empty Universe.
We thought that what would
happen is that it would look
like this, and either collapse,
or not.
What actually happened is,
it turns out,
things look like this.
We only really observe it in
the past, so there's a whole
bunch of supernovae proving that
that's true.
And you can extrapolate a kind
of gentle expansion that looks
like this.
This is the standard model with
a Cosmological Constant.
But if you assume that things
get even bigger--that the dark
energy increases per volume with
time,
then you asymptotically go to
infinity at some time in the
future and you blow everything
apart.
Not ruled out.
And so, people are anxious to
discover whether that,
or some other set of crazy
ideas, might be true.
And we'll talk about how people
are going about trying to nail
this down next time.